it's that moment where I've committed to  leaving but I haven't left the earth yet  nothing you can do but charge forward  what I love the most in doing things is  that I can do anything I want it's pure  freedom you know there's always a bit of  here you don't have a little fear you  know then your little crazy I think  nothing else matter except here all the  chaos he's just gone no one else around  the moment my feet leave the earth  everything else disappears it's pure  adrenaline  nobody it's what I live for  the mountain is your canvas you know you  can paint your own picture that's what  the beauty of it is the most important  thing for me is to try something that  never been done  am I scared sure but fear can be a tool  it can keep you performing beyond what  you think your limits are